hey guys it's Justine and we are at the
Samsung Galaxy unpacked event and guess
what we have here this is the samsung
galaxy z flip say now before the event
even happened and they aired a
commercial at the oscars which was kind
of incredible because there were rumors
but the oscars commercial just confirmed
it and here it is it's in my hands
[Music]
so this is the Z flip it has a six point
seven inch AMOLED Infinity flex display
within one foot one inch AMOLED display
on the front when you DoubleTap on the
power button which also is a fingerprint
sensor this will activate the selfie
camera so you can take a selfie look at
that it also has wireless charging but
it isn't 5g compatible with the rest of
the s 20s it's running a Snapdragon 820
5 plus that's eight gigs of ram - and 56
keys of storage and a 3300 milliamp dual
battery there's two 12 megapixel cameras
in the back there's a wide-angle and an
ultra wide-angle and on the inside of
course it has a selfie camera and that's
10 megapixels it comes in three
different colors there's mirror purple
black and gold in some markets they also
have one other version this is the Tom
Brown edition this one is a limited
edition version and they're launching it
at New York Fashion Week they only get a
few minutes with this thing go the crazy
part about this is this is being
released on Valentine's Day so what a
treat to us you can get it at various
retailers and the fact that this is
being launched so soon without
pre-orders or anything was kind of
shocking but I saw that flash up on the
screen it was a great a minute that's
just a few days away so initial
impressions is it doesn't feel cheap
like I feel like one of the things that
when you have a flip phone like this I
never really had much time with the
Samsung Galaxy fooled but one of the
things that I'd like about this is this
feels substantial like when this is in
my hand like it feels nice let me do a
pop it test this isn't a real pocket
what kind of lie is this put it my buck
do you have a pocket in Jenna's pocket
because I don't have one that's nice
flex that's cool give it back
so it's cool about this is different
applications will change depending upon
how you have the phone so right now we
have the full screen mode we're watching
YouTube
but if we fold this the video will
continue to play up top but down below
you have all of your YouTube comments
and you can basically interact with this
like a little tiny laptop you can also
do full-screen mode some other things
that I really like is this hinge it's
really stiff so it's here to place this
somewhere it can basically kind of act
as like a little tripod made it a little
demo at the keynote where you could take
like a selfie or you can do google duo
calls I like this because it doesn't
feel like it's just gonna shut on its
own and speaking of closing it you have
over 200,000 folds they say you can't
tell that there is a little bit of a
crease but this doesn't feel like
plastic because it's actually a very
very ultra thin glass do you see me do
you see it
I just took our picture using the front
flip how cool so this is just my first
look at the samsung galaxy easy flip
this is pretty cool I love the future
thoughts of the integration of having
foldable phones like this because taking
something that is this big holding it in
half and it is now half the size I'm
definitely really into that as i'ma say
I wish that I could do that with my
laptop but technically that's kind of
what you're already doing well see you
guys later
I'll have some more videos coming out
soon so make sure you like comment and
subscribe and sure to hit the bell and I
will see you in my next video gentle
your turn thank you
go oh I need a thumbnail did you see
what colors it comes in yeah in the vo